hey welcome back to the monitor I am
Peter Rubin senior editor at Wired and I
want to start this week with burning
love which is a parity reality show the
start of Monday night on e love parody
reality shows when they're done well so
often they're not this one is it is a
parody of the bachelor type competition
romance romance competitions reality
whatever you want to call it this stars
Ken Marino who you know and love from
Party Down and Veronica Mars and his
time on the state and the the would be a
loves of his life you will recognize
from other comedy shows like party down
and Children's Hospital from adult swim
what's so nice about the the place in
the comedy world that the state and
their alumni now inhabit is that they've
surrounded themselves with people who
are great at at living and graded improv
and nothing demands that like a parody
of reality show that's what makes real
husbands of Hollywood so good and that's
what makes burning love so good new
episodes premiere every Monday night and
of course it being either going to rerun
it all week because what the hell else
are they going to air well probably
keeping up with the kardashians I
shouldn't even ask that question at any
rate burning love definitely worth a
check let's talk about music at long
last atoms for peace has released a
studio album it's called a mock now
atoms for peace is one of thom yorke's
side projects or maybe collaborations
now thom yorke who's of course the lead
singer of radiohead has been making his
solo projects for a few years now making
a lot of electronic music and some
people have accused him of trying to be
the next Prince of dubstep or some such
ridiculous over K I would not go that
far but atoms for peace consists of Thom
Yorke and fully of course the bassist
from Red Hot Chili Peppers and long time
Radiohead producer Nigel Godrich and a
few others what's nice about this is it
takes Tommy York's love for electronic
music which in his hands can be really
kind of skittering and and detached and
it pairs it with instrumentation so it
ends up kind of finding that happy
medium between his his
really just nothing but pared down
electronic music and radiohead his
vocals are always going to be kind of
lush and haunting and there's always
going to be this kind of unease behind
the music but they pair together really
really well and it's just a nice record
atoms for peace a mock out this week
check it out let's talk about video
games old-school gamers rejoice Capcom
last week began this long series called
Capcom arcade cabinet which is going to
be a series of reissued old school or
retro games that are playable on xbox
live arcade or the PlayStation Network
it kind of comes in one container in
which you download these packs of games
which are going to be released every
couple of weeks for the next few months
the first pack consists of black tiger
the Avengers and 1943 the Battle of
Midway if you miss your day is pumping
quarters into arcade cabinets as a wee
tyke it is time to get it on with a dual
shock or a gamepad it's a lot of fun at
the end of this they're going to be
releasing all the games with kind of a
bundle price but if you can't wait that
long good to get two or three games at a
time or wait and see the release
schedule in the future they're going to
be games like ghosts and goblins and
commando and all sorts of other retro
Capcom delights but for now starting up
get your hands on it that's it for the
monitor this week we will be back next
week with more pop culture loveliness
but until then inspirational catchphrase
here